I'm Torsten Wiesel and newest
neurobiologist and I like to talk about
some discovery that David Hubel and I
made some starting out 60 years ago and
this picture is from when we started out
David Hubel to the left and me to the
right and we had just finished our
medical studies and decided to leave the
climate and try to see if he could not
advance our understanding of the brain
by doing basic research in neuroscience
and the we were very our attitude was
very much the one over Explorer we
theists had tools in a hands and and we
were interesting to understand her hobby
visual images on the retina how they are
being processed by the brain so we can
see things in detail and color depth and
so that was and no one really had at the
time studied self in the in the Israel
cortex it was a virgin territory and so
we had no hypothesis no real theory how
it should work we just wanted to using
the method of recording from single
nerve cells in the brain then try to see
what how the system works the simple
simple-minded idea and we were very
fortunate in that we were able to come
to the laboratory of of Steven Kotler
who was already at the time he was
working his lab was in the basement of
the Wilma Institute at Johns Hopkins
Medical School
it was a simple setup and we got the
room there and the reason why we were
happy in the basement was that Steve
Cooper was a it was a brilliant person
in his in his work and his main interest
was in synaptic transmission how the
synapse the connection between nerve
fibers and cell no cells work it's a
very fine and that was his passion but
since he was at 9 C 2 T also it starts
did some work on the retina he recorded
some single retinal ganglion cell and
and this was the fundamental work that I
will just describe in a bit that really
laid the foundation for the work that
David and I carried out in sorted out in
the basement so David you will he he he
I was Canadian in yet and he had already
shown his talents in a new size he was
working in McGill University for a bit
and then he he doing this child he
developed the micro electrode that
tungsten micro electrode which was
really a major advance and I had heard
him give me talks about he has recording
from a wide awake cat using a very
elegant technique that he developed
himself but actually later on was the
model for the the work that's now still
be going on recording from a wake up why
the way monkeys in particular and he he
was very skillful in terms of
instrumentation he had a lathe in the
lab and could build zone equipment so I
think for me over to her
such a not only skillful technically but
also brilliant a mind to person to work
with was I think my great fortune in my
scientific area so the combination of
culture and they really set me off in a
good start
the the this is a picture of the micro
lecture you can see the thing coming in
from the right and coming close to a
nutshell the Novosel is staying here
with a silver stain to show the cell
body and the processes and it turns out
when you put the electrode close as you
can see here to the cell body you can
record the wall and on action potentials
that cells no cell use to communicate
with each other so this all along action
potential travel down or to a long
process called an axon that then goes to
another no cell M is communicate with
that so the frequency the action action
potential is is an all anon signal that
changes in frequency and depending with
the information that conveys from one
cell to another is through the changes
in the frequency of the firing of the
cell and once the signal come to the end
of the axon the terminal the transmitter
released and you then have an analog
transformation of the digital signal so
so that's how the nervous system works
the digital signaling over long or short
distances and then an analog who would
process signals have from thousands and
thousands of individual interests to the
cell so this sounds very complicated but
it
turns out that as you see in a recording
that will show that it you actually can
receive information useful information
by this recording and just to give you a
little bit of a background let me show
you the system that we used in our
studies initially we learned as I said
in the basement and we had we we had
very little money and we the only thing
we had available was this blackboard and
also an old slide projector we could put
him and and Remy has an amplifier and
the animal was sitting behind David
could look at the screen and then we
project them images onto the small
papers that you see tagged on to the
blackboard and this was them our method
of stimulating the receptive see the
area light sensitive area of seeing
themselves it might be easier to
understand this by reducing at this say
a graph this is a human head over CV V
only works on anesthetized cats and
monkeys but the system is very similar
in man and particular in in the monkey
and so here you can see the the eye and
the the person here is looking at the
screen and you can see the squares on
the screen and the eye projects them to
real a nucleus retinal ganglion cells
project and these really not just
project to the to the to the visual
cortex which is some the two circles so
the first circuit of the relay nucleus
and the big circuit is the primary
visual cortex and David and I we spend
about twenty years trying to understand
of this beautiful structure work
now the the one thing is important to
remember that he give even if there are
there are million fibers coming in from
the eye to the to the lateral in their
clothes and there are hundreds of
millions of cells in the primary visual
cortex but even if there are this large
number of cells you can see it by
looking at one cell at a time you will
as you will see you can learn a great
deal about all the system works at some
people have said that David an IV broker
could about how visual information was
ptosis from the eye and then by the
brain so we or I like to to to keep in
mind that it different cell can only see
one of all the square what we called
this light sensitive area or the
receptive field of a cell and you can
see that here see the horizontal bar so
a single cell can see that it's recall
then the receptive see the light
sensitive area the the chin you're going
to hear it sounds when you put the
electrode close to the nurse'll for the
action potential to all and all signal
it's an amplifier connected so you can
hear a plot when the fire shall send a
signal and it's the frequency of the
stops that we hear that indicate the
signal so the you're now going to hear
the signal from one single nerve cells
first from from the rail a notice and
them from the cortical cell another
thing you need to do is that when Steve
Kutcher recorded from red Meganium cells
he showed that they responded very well
to small spots of light but not to big
spots because they have a sensitive
center and an antagonistic surround
as you by stimulating a big spot you
antagonize the cell as well as exciting
it was not as expensive as you
stimulating the center now David and I
found that the cells in availa nucleus
here at the same properties they like
small spots but not big spots so so and
then we will see when you record from
cells here in the primary visual cortex
he found that they don't respond small
spot alive he was very frustrating and
was only by chance we discovered what
you will see in the movie in a few in
the second so first in a movie you will
have recording them from the single cell
in a lattice naked body and then without
transitioning or differently in the
pitch of the sound and you record from
the saltiness camera shutter clicks so
so here is stimulate now in the center
of that square which is the receptive
field sensitive area of the cell and you
can hear a strong response okay here you
can see them the cell responds very well
to small spot of life to make a spot
large and it's less effective not as
crisp as for and the reason is as you
can show here that you stimulate here
the surround is antagonistic and so far
and we turn it off it fires also okay
and so you can see how this antagonism
function by contracting have a big spot
to contract it to small spots in the
cell five because you take away in
addition it's just showing the centers
around arrangement that cookie was the
first show again assistant Uniqua so now
we go just to show that this is the sofa
symmetric kind of organizational that's
the fear and to show that we have the
Power Move
I chose it as a CI a-- disappointed and
you can hear less there's no real
difference in the treatment will be
impulses from field only recording from
the single nerve cells in the real end
of this now we have certainly a pitch to
change and you can hear that inaugural
recording from a single cells in the
primary supporters and we have map out
the light sensitive area receptive field
or a single cortical cells and it's very
you can see the blackboard we have
before very simple and going on this
piece of paper the line outline and the
size of the cheese is completely bigger
than indicated here and orientation is a
little bit more enterprise but in
principle this is actually an experiment
that David and I carried out some fifty
years ago and we just wanted to have it
documented because first people didn't
believe that it was to sell had this
property that you'll always be it stem
cells is this elephant will be better to
lesser movements are right and some
cells here respond only the one
direction and ourselves to for one over
the other so this is the critical points
coming up now keep in mind we are simile
the same visual area recording but this
cell doesn't see a horizontal part and
only see bar along the words this is
native amazing feature and they by
asking and exploring the nature the
brain program about this trick next year
sure
input Cambridge is too soon to show you
how our stone on simple description L if
we detect ma orientation of an
accomplished
so the I'd like to go back now to this
diagram just to point out that within
the within the receptive the area
receptive field the light sensitive area
the cell you you saw before sort of
closer vertical orientation now when
David I first discovered this a chance
actually it wasn't because we were
clever it just happen at the contour of
annoying disorientation happened to pass
by and and we say Oh what does this mean
because she couldn't activate the shells
but spots alight so David who was very
heroes down the whole cold on our
colleagues to come to look what what we
have found as everybody came and were
amazed like we were about the
specificity ourselves or responded for
your monumentation over any other but
within this square here there are many
others neighboring cells open for a
different orientation the drawing here
we have a horizontal and there are other
oblique orientation perhaps there is a
rotational twenty different orientation
so but to sell all these cells we see
the same little area so you have to
think about our visual system is
postulated into small light sensitive
areas and then it's not until you get
into high visual areas when these areas
come together you have bigger areas of
light sensitivity so you can see the
whole or the whole world but the initial
step in the processing of issues of
information is this population of images
and the idea here is a D cells sensitive
orientation of a country or the
instrument used by the brain to
visualize to rick which make it possible
for us to perceive any object
this slide is from a book by the late
David Moore who who was a he liked the
idea about animals more model builder
and he he he said that if you look at
the teddy bear and you have these health
sentences the cult orientational contour
and he drew here to the right the the
here the vertical the oriented
self-referring and up top of the head
you can actually draw the the teddy bear
using these very simple cells so that's
that was the that was the concept to
that that it's like having a label set
and you come and you can look upon these
cells as having individual pieces that
then the brain can use in order to
depict any object or interest now the
funny thing happened when when we
published this paper in the spring of
1969 not a figure but the fact that
visual primary visual cortex successive
cells they are central to orientation of
contours I received no so we received a
note from yeehee Young who was a very
prominent neuro biologist in Britain and
he said Torsten now this is very very
nice but is nothing new and then he sent
me this picture of the fungal
self-portrait so you can see as you can
see van Gogh youth-oriented lines in
order to draw his picture and other
artists have also used similar ways and
so you can ask maybe artists to have
more intuitive understanding how our
brain works and they obviously don't
realize it but and we don't either
necessarily but this is one way perhaps
that we should like to bring
arts and sciences together that by
working together you may learn from each
other so the this was the the one
discovered this when we saw it out in
the September 19 1958 we discovered this
orient orientation of self sensitivity
specificity of a cortical felt
orientation after three months and so we
quickly wrote the paper then published
in the spring the point is to come back
to this slide is that to remind you that
this discovery is of work is a
critically important for our
understanding of vision of the visual
information is coded the thumb is very
simple but two young guys using very
simple tools and that one like to
inspire young people to if you have an
idea to just find out what you can do in
them go ahead is try out and then once
you find something worker can again with
visualization and the compound is the
proper lavatory which she did so David
and I continue to work this as I said
two very short time and later we spent
30 years together
April supposed to come as I mentioned
one month one year or his lab in North
castles were renovated but we got along
so well and so we stayed together
collaborate for 20 years and during
those 20 years we we did study the
cortical architecture we studied showed
that that orient cells with similar
orientation or groups in alumni
organization very beautiful way and the
two eyes worked together in a very
precise way also in a columnar
fashion and we patrol so that the
development of the visual system what is
we are born with and how that can be
modified by the environment so this is a
long story but the the fact that we had
visuals on time but I just started out
very simply I think this is a remember
of course we then in 1981 we were told
that we had won the Nobel Prize oh and
this is just press conference in that
context we both looks happy now
David the continue to stay at Harvard
for until 2013 when he when he died and
I still feel strongly that I used to
call we used to college or scientific
brothers and that true he became
scientifically very close and enjoyed
each other's scientifically whereas at
the same time we had our own personal
lives so but it was a real Brotherhood
type of scientific brother situation so
I still miss the guy so thank you